sup guys welcome back to a brand new
video and I'm sorry for the lack of like
enthusiasm or five FS aunt too quiet I
have a feeling that great the past
couple days I'm kind of feeling like
[ __ ] so I apologize for that but we're
going to be talking about North Stars
flight core and just north star in
general and how we should fix her I've
been pulling about an hour to with her I
can already tell that there's some
things that need to be changed a bit so
one of the things I came up with is the
adjustment to her flight cord and for
example I was playing on homestead LTS I
had a legion with about half health and
I popped the IPOP the flight core and he
just plowed through me now give it give
or take that you know Legion probably
had his gun shield up which is
completely fine but the fact the flight
cord doesn't do as much damage as it
should is kind of disappointing and plus
you're leaving her out in the open North
Star is a Titan doesn't have a lot of
helped she's on par with Ronan tell
she's the Strider chassis so there they
are the two Titans with the least amount
of health and you're giving the Titan
with the least amount of health the one
ability that they're not supposed to
have to leave them out in the open this
flight core shoots you up in the air and
then you're expected to plow down tons
of enemies of titans or maybe even one
but you're getting plowed down yourself
by a legion with his gun shield I on
with his shield scores with his shield
or just tone plopping his particle wall
at you that you can't even fly over
because the distance of the of the wall
is way too high for you to fly over
you're just getting pelted and since
you're the lowest amount of health
possible for a Titan you're getting
destroyed immediately as soon as you pop
the flight car so I believe that you
should have the ability to either get
out of the core like cancel it about
halfway through or they should adjust
the damage on this thing another thing
that I've been noticing is that they
need
to change the speed of the railgun now
certain instances it's not that bad when
you're like a long distance fight which
is north stars like perfect situation
being long distance staying as far away
as they can the problem is when I ronin
runs up on you or when a bunch of other
Titans start gang banging on you what
are you going to do with your railgun
you have to charge it up to even do
enough damage to either scare them off
or to do or some damage to like I don't
know doom one of the titans so that it
can be a fair fight this thing needs to
be changed intimate needs to be made
faster the last idea I had was to give
North Star a getaway ability now I know
the tether is kind of her escape ability
but it takes a while to recharge but for
example someone on reddit said this so
shout-out to him they said that they
should have the tether trap when it's
laid down and it let's say a legion
activates it there should be an
electrical current that kind of shocks
them now they did say that there could
be an arc grenade type of field where
blinds them but there might be a bit too
much but just in general just have it
shock them and do like little bits of
damage nothing huge as long as she's not
overpowered with it just little bits of
damage to help her be more not viable
because she's already viable but be more
picked so the more people can play her
and not have trouble trying to deal
damage with her and then getting
frustrated that's going to be really the
end of the video and I like and at this
at the beginning I said that my voice on
it a lot you know not as enthusiastic
and a lot quieter I'm sorry I just don't
feel that great the past couple days
it'll get better soon other than that
just like the video if you enjoyed
comment your opinion on if these should
be if these are great ideas and if you
have any other ideas please be feel free
to share them I'm always looking for new
ideas to see and subscribe if you're new
because I'm going to be putting out
plenty more titanfall videos in the
coming future so stay tuned for that
guys and peace out